[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host
grace helbig a very exciting very
festive
holiday fueled episode awaits you with
mary holland
oh she is just so lovely if you don't
know her get ready to meet someone that
is hilarious sweet charming all of it
she's jane in the happiest season uh
now on hulu the kristen stewart holiday
film
it's absolutely wonderful she also
co-wrote the movie so fantastic
uh we talk about wild horses her improv
troupe that she still performs with that
is doing virtual shows
we talk about her love of lord of the
rings survivor
how she and her husband got married in
their carport on halloween this year
she said quite a year and this was such
a lovely conversation so please
enjoy this episode of not too deep with
mary holland
[Music]
mary hi i'm so excited to talk to you
i'm uh
i have a million questions um happiest
season
obviously the coolest thing right now
i want to get to that in a second yes um
but let's start at the beginning i want
to hear how you got into comedy i know
you're a huge ucb person
um and so i'm curious how you found
yourself in
in new york right l.a
oh in l.a yes yes um
so i moved to los angeles right after
college
um drove across the country and
uh oh you did the the full drive i did
nice i did uh yeah i went to college
outside of
chicago um so i drove from there
and yeah i i
actually the one of the first apartment
buildings i lived in was
right down the street from the upright
citizens brigade theater in
los angeles um so it was actually
a geographic you know
coincidence there but i had done some
improv in chicago uh while i was in
college and so
um i was a little familiar with
long-form improv but the the ucb in la
was like two years old at that point
it had been in new york for a long time
but um they had just opened their their
la branch and i went
to see some shows there and was like hey
i know this stuff this is yeah this
improv
um and so i started i signed up started
taking classes and
um and yeah just got
very into the improv sketch scene
very cool like so when you did improv in
chicago was that something
were you interested in theater and this
was kind of another
offshoot to like make yourself
well-rounded or were you interested in
comedy specifically
yeah i was i was going to school for
uh for theater i got my bfa in acting
from
northern illinois university and we we
really rarely did
comedies it was a lot of um
very like emotionally fraught
like yeah yeah yeah theater pieces a lot
of
drama which i i love doing and and so
grateful that i
i got that experience um
but yes i feel like when i started
getting into improv
i really just i loved the
the sense of play and the um
it was such an important creative outlet
and i was meeting all these people that
i just connected with and
and fell in love with and it it became
my community in such a such a big way
and then
additionally all the the skills that
improv has taught me
that i've been able to use in my
professional life but also my personal
life like
you know so many of the philosophies of
improv art
are really great like they really are
guidelines yeah they're truly just like
foundational tools for building
relationships like
romantic and platonic but i forget that
i went to the people's improv theater in
new york and so oh yeah
i forget that a lot of the just the
things that i've learned there
truly are the way i
give other people any advice about just
like operating in life that i'm like
wow these do really map into the real
world so
effortlessly they really do and it's
also just
like how to how to i i totally agree
with you about relationships
and then it's also like just from a
mindfulness perspective like
how to like stay in the moment and and
not pre-plan or like be attached to
results
just kind of trust that you're
you're you're going to be supported and
you'll be taken care of and it
like fosters this um courage i think
that's so
important totally totally totally and i
think i saw
um because you have an improv group wild
horses
yeah and you guys have been doing uh
live stream
shows is that true we have yes we we did
a few at the very beginning of
uh the pandemic yeah so like in early
march
and then there was a few months where we
were all coping
and then we we did just start doing
shows again and i think we're gonna try
to do them monthly now
um but we do it through this yeah we do
through the theater called dynasty
typewriter um
that has pivoted really beautifully to
like
doing online shows like
they really have made it so seamless and
easy so i hope we do more
yeah i mean kudos for the for pivoting
because i
am so curious that's something that
strikes me every now and then is like
how are improv groups handling
the last eight months because it's like
truly impossible
to do that kind of stuff but to know
that you guys are doing it on a live
stream
how is what's that experience like i'm
sure it's very
different but some of it must feel
familiar yes yes it is
very different but there in a way
there's like some cool
things that we can play with within this
structure that we
that we couldn't do in person
for example i remember we did this one
show and
in the improv portion of the show there
was
uh my character was like taking
over the the the room or there was some
sort of situation where my character was
like
um an evil like overlord and so i
i like from zoom could mute
all the other facts women in my group
and they did they like took that and ran
with it they like pretended like they
were trapped and like
that's so great so it's cool it kind of
it
it really uh makes you be creative with
with how your
um what you normally would show
physically
how you can you know translate that to
to
a two-dimensional like screen is really
fun
it's great to know that you're still
able to do it too because it must feel a
little bit
like you know i mean it is a drug in
some sense like the endorphin rush of
being able to
create something from nothing so to have
a little bit of that
a little bit of uh of the fix must feel
really nice yes
oh my gosh i mean it's such a huge part
of my life
like it improv is um when you're
in that community and in that world
you're doing
shows constantly or practice groups
you're just like constantly working that
muscle
and um yeah it's tough to
not have that that outlet
but i'm glad that we found a way to make
it work somehow
totally um and things that are currently
working
let's talk about happiest season because
this is such a delightful movie
it's like thank you so funny
and grounded at the same time like it's
a really wonderful balance
and you you co-wrote the film
yes yeah tell me about that process
yeah so clea had the idea for happiest
season
uh for a long time and and when we met
working on veep we
just really hit it off with each other
we didn't know each other very well at
all but
um i feel very lucky that she
uh asked like took me out to coffee and
told me about the idea she had and the
story she wanted to tell and
and uh asked me if i would write it with
her and and i
was like well yes
well yes absolutely i would love to very
much yeah
very much so and very much so um yeah so
how long ago
was this that you guys started writing
it it was almost
uh oh my gosh i it just hit me that it's
december um it was almost four
years ago wow yeah i feel like we
started in december or january january
of 2017.
wow so yeah it's kind of wild
it's really wild and it's it's a
beautiful story
to tell and it's right it's a real like
i said it's a great balance of making it
funny and lighthearted but still keeping
like the core
uh i guess you know conflict very
grounded
and real for people um were you
pulling characters or anything from real
life situations i know that you're close
with your sister
so i didn't know if any of uh the
characters have been informed by
actual family members no no not really i
i did i do not have the same
relationship with my sister as
the sisters in the movie um but i do
think that that
that sisterly dynamic is
is so specific and really
intense it's like i know with my sister
we were each other's best friends
growing up and and that
you're also around each other all the
time and you're growing up together
and so yeah there's just so many layers
to that relationship
and we we wanted you know to get to know
harper through that
through that relationship so giving her
sisters was a
was a really cool way to get to know her
better
um and yeah i mean the the the story
itself was inspired by
cleo's experiences and you know
holiday movies are important to both of
us and i think
it was really important to clea to see
her experience represented
yeah and this genre and of course you
know
lgbtq plus stories should be there
should be so many
in all genres so i it is very exciting
that that we get to
um tell this one on such a large scale
now what are your normal christmas movie
go to's or holiday movie go to's
home alone is at the top of the list
okay okay
um die hard die hard i would say we
watch
uh my my husband matt is adamant that
die hard is a christmas movie
okay and i agree it feels like a
christmas movie
um uh let's see scrooge
watch every year um
yeah family stone i mean they they
really become a part of
one's tradition and and something that
like brings a lot of comfort every year
so
um it was great making one yeah and
the cast is like every person involved
is so
wonderful and clearly brings their own
essence to these already very funny
characters and interesting
complex characters and it feels like um
well i'm curious about the casting
process like did kristen stewart come on
and then it sort of like happened or
was it were you able to bring in friends
and that sort of thing
right it really clea as the director
um really captained that that process
and she was so mindful about
um bringing in people that uh
are brilliant actors i mean this cast is
just full of
such oh it's fantastic fantastic
it's like such stellar performers and
um but she was also really mindful of
bringing in people too
who were warm people
and and generous and positive and uh
so i she really just
curated this incredible group of people
and um
and yeah and that when we were writing
it with these characters really
really you know stood on their own and
it was a world that
we created that would you know exist on
his
own and then all these actors stepped
into these roles just
and did the most wonderful things with
them i they're so lucky
that's so cool especially like just the
trust in knowing that they're going to
take the things that you've written
and just elevate them must have been so
cool it was
a marvel to watch it was so great now
how has
the feedback been because now it's it's
out it's available for everyone to see
people are watching it and it's kind of
like truly ideal timing for everyone to
have
a very sweet and beautiful story around
the holiday season
right right the the response has been so
overwhelmingly positive and um
i've heard from lots of friends and
family who have been so
enthusiastic and supportive and then
i've heard i've heard from a lot of
people who i
i don't know who have reached out and
and um
told me like how how much this movie
means to them or how it's impacted them
or you know and
it's been really wonderful also to hear
that it's
it's starting a lot of conversations
between
uh families and friends and loved ones
and that
that is um that is really beautiful to
hear
yeah was there any hesitation on having
it come out
this year we're wanting it to be pushed
another year because of the state of the
world
right i i don't know what those
conversations
were like i mean i i feel like
we all really felt like this was a movie
that
we need yeah yes this year and
yeah so i i feel like the
the move that was made um hulu
taking it on and and sharing it and
uh you know having the support of sony
and tristar in that
in that effort to like get it out into
the world and have it be so accessible
i think that that was just the the best
possible
way we could enjoy it and there's
something too about it
i mean of course we would love to to see
it in the movie theater that's right you
know
what a dream but it's also it's sort of
the the image of people safe at home
you know being able to like enjoy this
from um
from the comfort of their homes and and
with their families is
what an ideal way to watch it very i
mean that's a very sweet optimistic way
to handle this whole thing i mean i saw
on your instagram that you're
uh the dress you wore for the premiere
stunning mask and all the paint
yes my my stylist was
so wonderful she um was able to get a
mask made with
like part of the dress so it all matched
and we love that very cool what was the
experience having a premiere was it a
drive-in
situation yeah it was a drive-in yeah it
was
so magical it was really
like ugh i love a drive-in movie
and to get to watch this movie and that
in that context was really exciting and
we
we had like little snacks and hot apple
cider and it just felt
very special and um
and so many so many friends turned out
and i'm just thrilled we had a way to
like celebrate it but still be very safe
and
yeah there's something even though you
could only do a drive-in situation it
does kind of feel like the ideal
like sweet holiday viewing experience
like a little
a little retro but a little comfortable
and quaint and cute
totally agree yeah very cool what it
felt like
okay we're gonna take a quick break when
we get back um i have
so many questions about the carport
wedding that happened this year for you
so
[Music]
hi friends grace helbig here from the
podcast not too deep which you are
currently listening to
hosted by me grace helbig just wanted to
say a couple of things one
thank you so much for listening and two
if you are enjoying yourself to such a
degree that you'd love to leave
us a review on the apple store
that would be so appreciated because
again you are very appreciated for
giving us your time your ears your
attention
whatever it may be uh and that was my
couple of things
now back to me me
okay let's talk about not only have you
uh made this beautiful film you've also
made a beautiful marriage
happen this year what a wild situation
now tell me about this because you got
married in your carport this year
we got married in our carport you know a
dream venue
yeah we yeah we
had other plans for our wedding and then
when it was clear that that that um
shouldn't happen yeah we decided we
still wanted to get married on that date
and
um it felt really important to both of
us to like
have this really positive uh experience
happen this year and so so we
we just uh decided to do it at home and
we
got like we have this little carport
area
um that we just hung a bunch of lights
in and then we
set up some tripods with phones
and we went this company called wed
fully
um coordinates virtual weddings
so uh they really had a very busy year
yeah i'm sure yeah but they they helped
us
figure out how to make this work and
like they facilitated
um uh greeting the guests when they
arrive on the zoom
and like uh they played a slideshow and
they like
uh our coordinator would toggle between
the two different camera angles that we
had set up in our car
it was really cool very creative yeah
yeah and it was it was very special and
intimate and and
creative and you know we getting married
on halloween
yeah this is a layered experience that
you guys
have not only is it in your carport and
it's this production value over zoom for
your family and friends but it's on
halloween as well
on halloween and this halloween was a
blue moon
we had it all going um yes and we
encouraged our guests
we told them you know please arrive on
the zoom however
you want like you can dress up or you
can like wear a costume we wouldn't say
no to that
and um the majority of people wore
costumes
oh that's fantastic that's fantastic
yeah my sister uh my sister was morticia
adams and her boyfriend was gomez at him
and then my dad hilariously
uh decided to the entire wedding be in
character
as kevin costner's uh character from
yellowstone
so he even he gave a toast to me
as kevin costner like
he even said he was like it's so it's so
sad that dwayne can't be here i know he
was
he was you know bummed to miss his
daughter's wedding but so i told him i
would be here instead and like
it was so sweet
okay so i was gonna ask like how do your
parents feel about you being in the
entertainment industry but it seems like
perhaps dad is maybe more supportive
than ever
yes he has he he is enjoying it
but yeah both my parents are um are are
doctors
so that wow yeah very much
an industry in a world that is new to
them yeah
i'm sure i'm sure yeah uh
but they seem like you know they seem on
board for it
yeah they're down they're down they're
down to have a good time
now in the film uh you have jinx monsoon
and bendel krem
there are you a drag race fan
i have just gotten introduced to drag
race
and i you know jinx
and ben delacreme i mean oh my gosh
their performance is in this movie were
i just could not take my eyes off of
them they're so
funny and so magnetic um
so yeah i can't wait to watch more drag
race
there's so much so much um oh i read
somewhere that
you had a ton of like quirky characters
that had to get cut from
the original script is that true oh yeah
well i mean you know the
a script goes through so many uh
evolutions yeah and you you start to
like
hone in on the story you want to tell
and um
and yeah i wouldn't say there was like a
ton
but there were certainly like a
character hero there that
that ended up you know not propelling
the story for it in the way we want to
but
that's always tough it's tough in the
writing process to like
um you know be be discerning like that
about what what is working and what yeah
what is it
yeah but it's great because all the
characters that are in it are still
incredibly funny but very real people
at the same time yeah that yeah that was
so
um important that
that all these characters had like uh
were three-dimensional and had a full
emotional journey that they also were on
you know in addition to this this main
story that we're following
so cool um i also want to talk about
golden arm
oh yeah which is crazy because
ironically we had um kate flannery on
this morning
in an episode yeah and she she brought
it up and it was so wild uh yeah so tell
us about
this this is uh the what i know about it
is
uh arm wrestling that's you know what
that's all you need to know
okay okay it's like a buddy
a buddy comedy um set in the world of
women's arm wrestling
and as directed by maureen barucha and
betsy sedaro and i play
the the two best friends
betsy is a trucker who competes
in women's arm wrestling tournaments and
i play her
best friend who's a baker and you know
is
is not in touch with her um
inner strength but she has this yeah
perfect
but she has this golden arm she has a
gift
like incredible um uh
arm so that you know it's all about her
journey and
oh embracing that part of herself it's
amazing
because the arm wrestling world really
exists
right this is an actual like oh yes
community this is an actual competition
did you have to do a research for this
or get into this world
absolutely it was it was written by
anne marie allison and jenna milley and
anne marie
um is a part of an
arm wrestling community in dc that then
they they do like fundraising events and
it's so
to hear her tell these stories like
people show up as their alter
egos and like dress up in full costume
and it's just really fun and celebratory
and we were lucky enough to have um dot
marie jones
she played in the movie she played um
uh the uh uh someone who trains me
okay and luckily we we that was like the
first
thing that we shot with that um series
of scenes
and it was so fortunate because
dot actually is a world champion arm
wrestler
uh wild she brought all her like belts
and tr like
it is amazing um but i haven't had
like i haven't had a many like things on
a short list that i really want to
go to once you know the world opens back
up but this is skyrocketed to the top
i'm fascinated by those and there's tons
of events like in l.a
and just all over so i'd definitely
check it out
but yeah dot was that was like in the
movie she's training me but then
she was actually like giving me tips of
like this is how you
do this and like you know how to prevent
like
breaking your arm and what you have to
do you have to get off the jump and all
this cool like
it was great that's amazing are there
any
uh any tips that help you know with the
carpal tunnel that comes from so much
internetting as well
you know she didn't go into any of that
um but i mean i feel like arm
wrestling's got to be good for it you
know
muscles so so maybe just get into
competitive arm wrestling
oh it's amazing so this is a film that's
coming out next year
yes yes okay cool cool for everyone and
when did you guys shoot this
we shot it not this past july but the
one before so
uh 2019 okay 2019.
oh that's so exciting uh i'm already
looking forward to it
uh now in general let's talk about how
how has quarantine been going for you
are you guys watching anything
are you binging anything what's been
yeah what's the
what's the latest that you're watching
i'm also just fishing for new
recommendations on things
oh great love it um yes it has been
definitely a time of of a lot of
consuming of movies and tv
and podcasts um the
the show that we we've been watching
most recently is the flight attendant
on april max i haven't seen that yet no
but i heard it's good it is so good it's
great
love it um and then i always have my
my go-to show that i just i have i seen
all of it yes but every time i rewatch
it
it is i'm finding new things i'm
learning new lessons and that is
um survivor on cbs yes okay
so my boyfriend and i at the beginning
of the pandemic 12 years ago
just got like super into survivor like
so late to the game
and that we are obsessed and we've gone
back
and watched i think we haven't watched
it in a while because we went too hard
and it got like very obsessive
uh but we've watched like the last 10
seasons or the 10 most recent seasons of
it
i'm obsessed with it obsessed it is such
a genius
genius genius show on television as far
as i'm concerned has been for 20 years
yes um yeah and i actually this is
this is interesting at the beginning of
quarantine
uh a friend of mine kelsey krasnogor
she started an online game that was
inspired by
survivor and it is like uh
all the challenges are over zoom and
like you're
unsocial it's like social strategy it's
that same
sort of like idea it's a brilliant game
it's called the quarantine island
i played it for a whole month and it
utterly
consumed me i can't even
tell you how intense it was
but i really learned a lot about myself
from doing it so i i highly recommend
everybody check that out quarantine fun
yeah yeah i i'm obsessed with the game
or
the show and the game um my friends have
been telling me about it forever and
it's something i hadn't watched from
like the first season once it came out
when i was in like high school or
college or something wild jeff probst is
like the greatest
host i've ever seen his ability to
facilitate
conversations blows my mind
he is an angel from heaven above yes
there is no one i love more and you know
what and i told my husband that and he's
okay
um yeah we just i love him so so much
now would you actually go on the show if
asked
listen if you had asked me that
i think at the beginning of this year
before i played quarantine island
yeah i would have said you know what if
they asked me i probably
would i just i love the show so much and
i love the game
yeah and um but after doing quarantine
island it has become very clear to me
that i am not cut out for it
you know i could never do it i could
never do it
i am i am too emotionally like
uh unstable and i i think i
would i would just be so
devastated to find out someone lied to
me because i think i
try to unfortunately see like the best
in people and and think that they're
good
yeah so i think in that game that would
be my achilles heels just being like i
trust you i trust you
i trust you yeah totally yes and it's
also like there
i i am definitely of the same
mind as you and then it's also when i
did try to
lie in the game i wasn't fooling
anybody i was so convinced i was like oh
i'm playing the game and everybody was
like well i know mary's line
yeah i know i feel like when i lie i
just get full hives
which would be the biggest tell to
everyone constantly i don't make eye
contact i just
look around like that exactly exactly oh
i'm so glad to hear that you're also
equally obsessed with that show yes
i'm so glad you are i mean it's it's the
perfect balance of social
commentary ah i love it also just to
know that everyone that goes on it now
is just clearly obsessed with the show
and so the way they play is so fast and
furious
that it's yeah it's hard to keep up with
really fun
yeah now is there a reality show you
would go on
oh man what a question would you and
your husband do an amazing race
or i we love amazing race i
i have brought it up to him a few times
he says
he says i'm not sure that that would be
good for us
i mean you really have to have a real
like uh
a partnership that is so the
communication has to be like
out of this world a hundred percent yes
yes
i would love to go on survivor i just
don't think i would
do well yeah i don't think i would
flatter myself in any
uh capacity i think people would be
upset with my inability to survive
on that show okay we're going to take
one last break when we get back i have a
bunch of questions for you from
instagram
so we'll be right back with more not too
[Music]
deep
[Music]
okay mary before we get into these
instagram questions i'm gonna ask you
the two questions i ask
every single guest that's on the podcast
and the first is
who alive or dead would you most like to
throw cold spaghetti
at cold cooked
spaghetti cold cooked spaghetti yeah
okay okay yeah
i mean gosh there's so many people i'd
like to throw that
no this is the one yeah this is
um
i mean
i think i would probably
like to throw it and is it is it
guaranteed to hit
their face it is guaranteed
to hit them in uh this ish
area and also the intention of how you
throw it is up to you it can be a
celebratory thing
it can be a mean spirited thing it's
whoever
depending on how you're feeling okay
okay okay great
great well i mean i think i'd like to
throw
cold spaghetti in like a fun way
maybe with someone like
in a garden that's a fantastic
answer oh because she would just catch
it
and then make something delicious yeah
in her blue button down
exactly jeffrey's in the other room
doing something who knows
who knows he just only he only comes out
for meal time
yeah exactly oh i love that uh okay the
other question i ask every single guest
is to tell us your
worst pants shooting experience or like
a bathroom emergency
but you can only use three words or
three small phrases to describe
the experience so grace mine
yeah i'll give you an example mine is
college jogging
front lawn yes tough time
very tough oh man okay well
listen i i okay there's a lot i'm
i'm so happy to hear that you have a
bunch to have a picture
i have a bunch of answers to that
question right but okay so
here we go i'm going to try to sum it up
in three words okay
dog walking jeggings
uh-oh
[Laughter]
jeggings yep
okay um
um what's the last word i would choose
there's so many good ones uh i would say
okay dog walking jeggings
fired oh no
that is a full movie that you've given
me yeah
yeah oh amazing no follow-up questions
there
great uh okay let's get into these
instagram questions we have a bunch of
them
well an overwhelming amount of them
first are asking
will there be a happiest season too
i sure hope so okay i sure hope so yeah
would love to do it uh it lends itself
to that
so many people uh want your character's
spin-off movie they want
strictly jane everything uh which is
very i would also love to see that i got
to see how the book sales do
and where she goes we have to know how
the book is changed
gotta know someone's asking what's your
favorite memory from filming happiest
season
it was such a special experience it
really was that this group of people
was so amazing and
we i feel like at the time we we all
knew we were making something really
special and important
and um we were all just so excited to be
there so
i i have so many great memories from it
but i would say
some some of my favorites are playing
games with everybody in the cast and
going and doing escape rooms together
those were a lot of fun that's so
fun who if anyone stood out as the worst
escape room participant listen
look if you were to ask all of us mary
steen virgin would say
she would claim that she's the worst but
i
totally disagree with that i think mary
uh was
so wonderful in the escape rooms
everybody brings their own strength you
know that's what's so great about escape
rooms is that
is that it really it really is a team
effort so
everybody everybody you know
brings their strengths to it everyone
has a unique talent for an escape room
yes um someone's asking does she try to
sneak her fellow wild horses crew
into projects or do they all audition
for similar stuff
i mean i think both both are true
uh you know we're all
brunette comedian
so we we do end up going out for a lot
of the same stuff
audition-wise but also uh
you know i i we're the comedy community
is
really supportive of
each other and so it it really feels
like
we have a lot of mutual friends who
bring us in for things and
definitely anytime i'm in a position to
to cast any of the wild courses i
would i'm over the moon to do it that's
uh
how long have the wild horses been
together as a group
we formed in 2013 so
uh almost almost eight years and how did
the name
come to be i remember we were on an
email chain look picking an improv
[Laughter]
a wild task it's a wild test
and every i mean you go from you
it can be anything and we were all
throwing out names and i
i remember lauren lapkins throwing out
wild horses
and we all were like that's it if that's
us
you have to wait yeah for the the
emotional connection to it
yeah now um someone is asking
what's your favorite way to wake up in
the morning
oh my favorite way to wake up in the
morning oh i love that question
i know well-rested
yeah i i have we have
um two cats and a dog
and our cats sleep in the bed with us
and so that i love waking up
and in at some point during the night
when i've been asleep
my cat has like crawled in and like had
me spoon
her and then waking up and discovering
that
such a pure joy yes
so nice uh someone wants to know what's
your favorite type of holiday attire
and why oh
yeah very intense i would say
tights yeah there's something about
i mean of course you can wear tights
year-round but there's something about
i i think it's probably i have an
association of like
dresses and tights with the holidays
from childhood i guess like you'd go to
like
church services and everything and like
always had like you know winter tights
on
and so that i have such a strong
correlation between those two things so
i
i would say i would say a dress in some
lovely tights holiday tights
love that um someone just says ask her
about fantasy stuff she loves lord of
the rings is this true
oh it's very true really yes yes it is i
mean you can kind of see my bookshelf
there that has gonna happen
well you have this beautiful color
coordinated
bookshelf that it's stunning it's so
aesthetically pleasing to look at
thank you i i it took me an entire day
[Laughter]
but uh i love i love fantasy fiction i
love lord of the rings that
that that whole movie trilogy and then
the the books and the hobbit
the the whole world that j.r tolkien
created i am just
so obsessed with it was a really i i got
so into it when i was
um a teenager and it just it really
became a part of my identity
very cool so if your character jane at
the end of this
you know co-writes a book did was that
influenced by real life uh of
affiliations affinity absolutely
absolutely yes jane
we we wrote jane um i like
early in the writing process when we
were brainstorming the the family
we knew we wanted one of the sisters to
like have a different energy than
everybody else and once we decided that
i
i told cleo that i wanted a player and
then
and so i feel like early on we started
like infusing
these details into jane that are that
are true of me too like
i also have night terrors and i love
fantasy fiction and so it was
it was really fun to get to write that
for jane
that she she is a really gifted author
oh that's so cool yeah well i was going
to say you
in the world of fantasy fiction what's
jedi temple challenge
jedi temple challenge is a um
kids competition game show that takes
place in the star wars universe
amazing and yes and i i played
um the droid sidekick to ahmed best
um who is the the host of the the show
and it features young padawans uh
trying to become jedi knights oh that's
so sweet
this is really sweet yeah how was that
experience it sounds like
sugar to the core uh sugar to the core
is a great way to describe it
and yeah i had so much fun and and
playing a droid is
uh a dream it's a dream
oh yeah i love that so much fun love it
love it um
okay someone is asking [ __ ] mary kill
your character from veep your character
from happiest season
and barack obama oh my god a very
specific question
i mean listen i would have to kill my
character from veep
she's a terrible person she
the the world would be well rid of her
um
so i would i would kill my character
from veep
i would
stop i would
it feels weird to say because
i played my character on happiest season
so it feels strange to say i'd
[ __ ] her right yeah how about that's
me how about um instead of
[ __ ] it's um you know uh redo a home
with okay well great great great
well i would i would marry
barack obama great choice yes
i mean of course and i would
be thrilled to redo a home with jane
she's so creative and has
so many ideas she's such a great artist
i know she is such a great artist
i love it there's a ton of questions
about riley and abby uh
and whether or not they should have
ended up together
how i'm curious if the end of the film
uh was easy to write or something that
you guys went back and forth
on it was always
important to us that abby and harper
have a happy ending with each other you
know yeah i think
we we really wanted to tell um
uh this story in a way that was very
honest and and uh authentic and feels
real and then also
you know give these characters a bright
happy
ending um so that was
always the the intention and uh but i so
appreciate the
the debate that's happening like it it
means a lot that people are really
invested in
well it's truly great because and
uh you know it keeps you hanging on till
the very end because you truly don't
know
where this is gonna go and it could be
yeah anywhere and that's what's so fun
about it
oh thank you yeah of course of course
uh now let's see someone asked how is
your back after carrying happiest season
it's very sweet everyone is saying
hashtag jane writes
that fell in love with jane uh
and then how does she feel playing a
literal icon
she's become an icon to me and my
friends i mean oh my gosh
yeah i think it's incredibly sweet like
that's a testament to how well written
all of these characters are that they
truly connect with real people in the
real world yeah
yeah i i that really means so much to me
i mean
it it is it is i know i really relate to
jane and and
it's um it's just been so moving to
to hear that so many people do and i'm
i'm just very grateful for that
oh that's so sweet um and last question
which i think you might have mentioned
in the beginning will wild horses be
doing any shows soon
yes yes we're hoping to start doing
shows monthly at dynasty typewriter on
online until we can until we can all be
together in person again
um amazing yeah so i think we're gonna
start doing that
in um january so we'll be
posting about that yeah well sweet um
mary this has been so fun
thank you for chatting with us thank you
grace before we wrap up completely
um we love to give a token of our
appreciation to our guests
and that is a personalized fortune
cookie from us to you
that i believe melissa might have
emailed to you
okay i see a fortune cookie and here's a
fortune and do i read it out loud
yes please okay be gay and merry
and check out happiest season on hulu
for your holiday season
but also honestly all year round viewing
pleasure if you don't have a login
we may know a girl there you go there
you go
there you go great fortune
the fates are in your favor now mary
where can everyone find you
where uh can they find every all the
projects you're working on or get
tickets to the upcoming shows etc
yes if you follow me on uh instagram and
twitter
at mary hollandaise i i post
i love that instagram handle by the way
fantastic yeah
i'm like keeping myself from
accidentally saying merry hollandaise
every time i say your name
i'm like you're welcome too i love it i
love it
um yeah i i post all info about shows
and
and
everything else that's going on there so
you can find all that there
awesome and very excited for golden arm
sometime
next year can't wait yes thank you
cool guys go check out everything that
mary is up to go
see happiest season it will leave you
feeling very happy
very sweet and uh we'll see you guys
next time on another episode of not too
deep goodbye
bye everybody too deep too deep too
deep deep not too deep with christ
not too deep as a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen lani eunis post
production sound by chris henry
and an extra special thanks to flula for
the theme music